[Música]
hasta la malecón hasta la malecón que la
paz esté con ustedes hasta la malecón es
la primera palabra que aprendí en árabe
de las pocas que sé aunque no me doy por
vencido porque sigo tratando de aprender
pero que me despertó curiosidad como
resultado de un momento en el que me
encontré en medio del desierto del
sahara trabajando con los refugiados del
pueblo saharaui la república árabe
saharaui del oeste es una nación
declarada como independiente y
reconocida por más de 80 países
alrededor del mundo entre ellos costa
rica
los saharauis se encuentran como una
nación en el exilio porque tuvieron que
salir huyendo literalmente por sus vidas
cuando su pueblo fue invadido y la única
opción que les quedó fue intentar
sobrevivir en el desierto
cuando yo estoy en este lugar me
encuentro en una biblioteca haciendo una
donación de unos libros y recuerdo que
me llamó la atención un muchacho que
estaba sentado a la par y que me al cual
me le acerqué y le empecé a hacer
conversación porque vi que estaba
leyendo algo entonces le pregunté que
que leía
él me respondió más que leer estoy
estudiando al eje yo entonces y qué
estudias me dice estoy estudiando
francés y yo a excelente o sea que a
parte de español porque estábamos
hablando en español árabe ahora quieres
aprender francés me dice bueno en
realidad también sé inglés y ahora lo
que quiero es perfeccionar mi francés
guau yo ya estaba sorprendido en ese
momento de la capacidad de aprendizaje y
de ohl y de y de deseo de superación en
medio de las circunstancias tan
drásticas que se puede encontrar una
persona como es un campamento de
refugiados en una zona completamente
remota
pero mi sorpresa no iba a quedar ahí
sino que en medio de la conversación con
él se vuelve y me dice
entonces ustedes son de costa rica-
verdad y yo sí de costa rica ustedes
saben que a veces es difícil para la
gente entender que costa rica no es
puerto rico ni cash no somos una isla
verdad pero en el caso de él fue todo lo
contrario se vuelve me dice yo siempre
tenía una pregunta acerca de costa rica
y yo
como si ya no estuviera sorprendido digo
yo así cuales me dice como hacen ustedes
un país sin ejército para sobrevivir en
el mundo wow wow wow
la capacidad que una persona tiene para
aprender es infinita no importa las
circunstancias en las que se encuentren
el era la prueba de eso
ese momento de emoción y de admiración
que yo sentí en ese momento se
transformó en tristeza cuando le
pregunté yo y cuáles son tus planes
ahora que ya terminaste la secundaria
para tu vida y me dice
la única
esperanza que me queda
y si algún país me regaló una beca para
poder ir a la universidad
porque ya mi pueblo hizo todo lo que
podía hacer por mí
la crisis de los refugiados y los
migrantes es la de las personas que se
encuentran en condiciones en las cuales
ellos tienen que salir salir de sus
zonas originarias
por el conflicto armado por el cambio
climático por situaciones en las cuales
su estabilidad y su sociedad ha sido
completamente destruida y entonces se
ven forzados a salir de estas regiones a
la fecha ya son más de 70 millones de
personas los que se encuentran en esta
condición alrededor del mundo
entre las poblaciones afectadas por eso
nosotros podemos encontrar que hay 4
millones de venezolanos que caminan a
pie para salir de la frontera de su país
encontramos que hay decenas de personas
entre africanos y asiáticos que se
encuentran cruzando y muertos en la zona
del darién aquí nomás ahí en el sur de
panamá le dicen la zona de las toma de
las tumbas no reclamadas nadie sabe
quiénes eran y de dónde venían
hay en este momento una gran cantidad de
jóvenes nicaragüenses tratando de luchar
por la esperanza de un futuro mejor por
el conflicto que se les viene y hay 3.5
millones de centroamericanos que han
tenido que dejar sus lugares de origen
por el conflicto del lugar este llamado
como el triángulo norte
[Música]
yo no sé
si es por una tendencia que nos ha
pasado a nosotros últimamente donde
tenemos la tendencia a analizar a las
personas desde lo que tienen y no desde
lo que son
es decir a veces pensamos en las
personas y decimos a este tiene trabajo
éste no éste tiene educación éste no
éste tiene documentos este no que en
base en ese análisis nos cuesta
identificar que los refugiados y los
migrantes son personas
con todos los derechos y con toda la
dignidad que eso implica
en medio de este contexto también es muy
triste ver como nosotros trabajamos
somos parte a veces de la degradación de
la condición de estas personas cuando
vemos que hay personas que utilizan su
dinero comprando cartulinas y marcadores
para escribir señales de odio
mientras que en ese preciso momento en
mujeres hombres y niños que son
maltratados secuestrados violados
asesinados en nuestras zonas de contorno
hay también una gran tristeza al ver que
muchas veces un tema que es meramente
humanitario se convierte en un tema
político cuando vemos cuando vemos
nosotros personas llevando sus campañas
con este mensaje promoviendo división y
promoviendo odio hacia una población que
ya de por sí es extremadamente
vulnerable en medio de esa condición yo
lo que veo es que ellos visualizan a
estas personas como si fueran a un
peligro para nosotros pero si nosotros
analizamos de esa forma de pensar desde
un pensamiento que decía thomas moore o
que decía más o menos así si nosotros
mal educamos a nuestra gente al punto de
que ellos crecen y se convierten en
delincuentes entonces que podemos
concluir nosotros a esto que primero los
maleducados para que luego se conviertan
en delincuentes y luego los castigamos
por lo que fueron destinados a cero
la crisis de los migrantes y refugiados
pueden ser una oportunidad grandísima
para muchas poblaciones como nosotros
costa rica- los migrantes son personas
que caminan con sus maletas por muchos
kilómetros pero que caminan también
con una gran cantidad de habilidades que
nosotros podemos utilizar si ustedes han
interactuado con migrantes y refugiados
se dan cuenta de la resiliencia que
traen de la esperanza que traen de la
innovación de la que son capaces de
hacer
de la estabilidad en medio de la
incertidumbre todas estas son son
habilidades super valiosas en el sector
laboral
a cummings una de las defensoras de
derechos humanos de las mujeres en el
mundo islámico decía que a través de la
educación nosotros podemos ayudar a que
las personas puedan avanzar
e integrarse en nuestras sociedades pero
sobre todo y como consecuencia de esto
traer justicia justicia social pero
sobre todo para aquellas personas que no
tienen los medios para avanzar en estas
situaciones sino es a través de la
asistencia estructurada
el aprendizaje continuo y las
posibilidades que tenemos hoy a través
del aprendizaje continuo nos dan a
nosotros un abanico de oportunidades
para poder apoyar a estas poblaciones a
que continúen aprendiendo ya que se
puedan insertar y ser productivos para
nuestra sociedad
sobre esta situación yo recuerdo
que una de las cosas que más me marco
para involucrarme
en el tema de los migrantes y refugiados
fue que cuando
las noticias impactado muchísimo sobre
reportaba muchísimo sobre la crisis en
siria
yo vi la historia de un muchacho que
decía que
y ya estando en europa
[Música]
que cuando él corrió en medio de las
bombas alistar su maleta
dice que lo primero que pensó en
llevarse fue su diploma de secundaria
porque con ese diploma él sabía que
podía continuar y salir adelante en
algún momento
los migrantes y refugiados
como les decía son una maleta que camina
con un montón de oportunidades
si nosotros aprovechamos las
herramientas como la tecnología hoy que
nos permite aprender constantemente y en
cualquier lugar en donde nosotros
estemos a través de un proceso de
educación continua podemos convertir a
una población vulnerable en una
población con un talento que nos puede
ayudar a nosotros a avanzar en tal vez
áreas en las que nosotros porque no
hemos vivido cierto tipo de
circunstancias estamos tal vez muy
sentados
he tratado de trabajar el tema de siria
y entonces cuando empecé a trabajar el
tema de siria me decían entonces usted
es de origen sirio no o sea el hecho de
que tenga piel morena y esta barba no
significa necesariamente que sea árabe
y luego empecé a trabajar el tema de
venezuela y me decían entonces usted es
venezolano no
ahora hemos estado trabajando de apoyar
el desarrollo humano de la zona norte
mismo y entonces usted de san carlos
no se necesita ser la causa para
apoyarla
nosotros como ciudadanos tenemos que
organizarnos y como países y como
regiones para apoyar a que estas
personas no tengan que pasar por la
crudeza de llevar estos tipos de viajes
tan peligrosos y tan atroces para sus
vidas
pero si eso nosotros no lo logramos hay
dos cosas que me gustaría que en las que
pensemos reflexionemos y actuemos si
esto no se logra número uno y escúchenme
bien población migrante y refugiada
usted no se sienta avergonzado nunca por
pedir ayuda a los países en que lo
reciben porque no es su responsabilidad
las condiciones atroces de las que usted
tuvo que salir por las que tuvo que
salir de su país y número dos cada uno
de nosotros como individuos tenemos la
oportunidad de transformar la vida de
otras personas con esta metodología de
aprendizaje continuo para que lleguen a
ser grandes hombres y mujeres en
nuestras sociedades como receptores
y si usted no sabe cómo hacerlo
piense en esto
qué pondría usted en su maleta si fuera
usted el costarricense que tiene que
salir de su país por una crisis que se
estabilice es costa rica que pondría
usted en su maleta y cómo le gustaría a
usted que lo trataran cuando llegue a
ese lugar
sobre todo pensando en que a todos nos
gustaría que nos trataran por quienes
nosotros somos por nuestras habilidades
y porque es lo que podemos hacer
su cara muchas gracias